raise a debt ceiling raise a debt
ceiling raise a debt ceiling raise a
debt ceiling a gear raise a debt ceiling
raise a debt ceiling raise a debt
ceiling right to debt ceiling again 30
trillion in debt and yo we back again
still written lots of money telling all
of your friends i told you this would
happen but you were a doubting thomas
dirty is the last trillion i'll ever
need i swear i promise printing and
spending for businesses we see hurt so
much theater stimulus they call me pee
wee herman it's like we're spending
junkies just getting an itch can i have
another trillion i promised my district
it was a crisis before we took the
lesson to heart by spending so much
money now with written press in the
church spending billions and billions on
military gear can he wind up with the
enemy what do you want to hear raise a
debt ceiling raise a debt ceiling raise
a debt ceiling raise a debt ceiling
again raise the debt ceiling raise a
debt ceiling raise a debt ceiling raise
a debt ceiling again back up in the fed
and we still superstore some are praying
lots of money why we working remote
still dropping i o using every fund yes
sir hamilton started this place that's
why the printer goes bird prices are
rising at every venue it's bad and for
sure that dollar menu looks especially
sad gas prices are rising it's getting
hard for the competition costs an arm
and a leg where am i the saudi consulate
inflating the money you should give it a
try someone used to sink your battleship
now it's what you used to buy one just
say the magic word i set the printer
above shaman might run out of paper son
because who never does waste a debt
ceiling raise a debt ceiling raise a
debt ceiling raise a debt stealing a
gear raising debt ceiling raise a debt
ceiling raise the debt ceiling raise the
debt ceiling again now if you examine
the chart and you look close again we
borrow more than 40 cents of every
dollar we spend non-discretionary
spending is a terrible basis do you have
a response yes
we should spend most on children we
should spend most on patience hear me
out why don't we spend most on interest
payments we're playing with fire we know
the end of the story how do you classify
your incompetence transitory objects in
the mirror are closer than they seem
into a man with the primary travel looks
like a ream but when i'm looking at the
folks that we've elected to lead i'm
guessing that it won't be long to win
back saying we need to raise a debt
ceiling raise a debt ceiling raise a
debt ceiling raise a debt ceiling again
raise a debt ceiling raise a debt
ceiling raise a debt ceiling raise a
debt ceiling again
let's never do this again
[Music]